welcome back everybody did you know may
is national barbecue month
so it's only right that we celebrate at
a restaurant that leaves you full
and famous check this out
[Music]
if you are celebrating national barbecue
month let's
meet here i stole that from the famous
dave sign outside
hi diane thank you for having us welcome
thank you for coming
oh it smells so good in this kitchen so
when families come in here
what's the go-to the all-american okay
for sure
there's enough of food to feed everybody
all right so let's what's on the
all-american plate i i got enough we
have a rib
which i will let you do the honors too
you're gonna let me
and you just flip it over okay what's
the technique just to slide it under
okay whoa clear back as far as there you
go
yeah there we go officially famous james
chef no okay i won't i won't take i
won't take the same dish
these are the stress back here but what
else goes into the all-american um it
goes with
a whole chicken a third meat of their
choice
french fries beans coleslaw and it has
corn corn muffins
on it wow this feeds four to six and
it's just the two of us can we do it we
can do it
we can do it no i understand you guys
have a couple different barbecue sauces
tell us about that we have our rich and
sassy which is award-winning
then we have a little bit milder it's
our sweet and zesty for somebody wants
that
molasses kick to it and then we have our
devil spit which picks it up a notch or
two
i'm going to stay away from the devil's
spit but i like the rich inside that
rich and sassy is the best where do
okay so anywhere you oh my god anywhere
anywhere anywhere anywhere i feel like i
just need it on everything
there you go
oh my gosh i'm excited famous rocky i
was telling you about our
famous rocky did you guys hear that i
like that everybody's famous
thank you famous diane you've got to try
one of our muffins
it's like the perfect mix of sweet and
salty oh my god yeah i'll take all of
these
okay and then i think i'm gonna need
something to wash
all of this down we have our
signature cocktails everybody loves our
adult cocktail signature cocktails are
handcrafted just for famous daves
and we do have a kitty version with
kitty crafted
soft drinks famous dave's also offers
catering we can cater
from 10 people up to 10 000 people we
also have a famous dave's
reward app this app is queue at your
fingertips
we offer online ordering third party
delivery
and also yes you can pick up in the
restaurants if you want
we'd love to have you in we have
locations across the valley
and we do accept reservations and
walk-ins also
and we are opening a brand new location
at paradise and harmon
and that's going to be our first fast
casual restaurant
and i want to wish everybody a famous
happy barbecue month
i will take a few more of those
cornbread muffins just saying all right
visit famous dave
on north rainbow boulevard you can call
them at 702-646-5631